So today we have,
uh,
our first.
Okay.
Today we have our first guest lecturer.
Uh,
my pleasure.
Thank you.
Do,
we'll be introducing you to a Dr. Michael title down.
And he was an undergraduate at Reed College,
uh,
where he double majored in biology and sociology.
That's,
that's an interesting combination and was five Beta Kappa and at the end of that
became a road scholar.
So how many,
how many prospective Rhodes scholars do we have in the class?
Who knows?
Then he went to Oxford as a biologist to study reproductive biology.
And your adviser died.
Is that your adviser died?
Well,
first he was paralyzed.
He died a horrible,
slow death.
Yes.
Yeah.
Something bad happens,
something terrible happen.
You then got into the statistical and quantitative aspects of that and that
eventually he got a phd in demography itself.
Uh,
and since then he's come back to America and he's taught at Oxford,
then Princeton and here at Yale.
And unlike most academics,
he actually has ventured into the real world.
Uh,
although I'm not sure these things are really real world,
like the u s government,
somewhat unreal.
And he was a staff director of the select committee on population for the US
House of Representatives.
And then he was yours commissioner for the study of international migration and
cooperative economic development.
So that pretty important.
Uh,
he has been with the Ford Foundation,
the Carnegie Endowment for Peace International Peace.
And he's now with the Alfred Sloan Foundation where he's been a vice president
and in charge of science and technology programs for them.
He's been on the advisory Boards and National Academy of Sciences,
National Institutes of Health,
American Association for the Advancement of Science.
He's authored seven books that I could only find four,
one,
two,
three,
four.
So in addition to your reading packet,
which I hope you've all picked up,
and this is just your reading for tonight,
you can do all that.
Uh,
uh,
fine.
In addition to the,
to this is half his books,
a five major government reports,
75 articles,
et cetera.
So,
uh,
and one of his major contributions is what we,
one of the topics we've just been just finished discussing.
Uh,
he wrote,
I think I mentioned this to you during the lecture that the part of the
Princeton project on Britain,
the book on the British fertility decline,
there's,
there's the author and uh,
the,
uh,
the times higher education supplement,
which is tough,
wrote on that book and unsurpassed profusion of original data presented at
analyzed with clarity all too often lacking in works of this time.
The book is invaluable.
It clarifies and orders to complex range of forces which underlie the modern
decline in rates of fertility,
et cetera.
He's also,
uh,
worked on a global environmental issues and population and resources.
The book,
this environmental,
my book is one of the best expectations.
So you have the honor,
not only for the lecture today,
but he's agreed to come to dinner and all the students were invited.
Uh,
we're going to be at,
at Timothy Dwight starting at five 30.
And I know you have other things.
If you can't,
we'll probably have a leasurly casual and leasurly dinner.
So,
uh,
if you can't get there,
five 30,
come when you can.
If you have something else afterwards leaving me,
come,
come and go.
But TD,
there's some sort of a,
of a small dining room and TD and so you can come for that.
Okay.
In the last lecture we discussed the fertility decline in Europe and then on
Tuesday we discussed how this fertility decline in discuss started discussing
has continued in Europe and spread around the world.
I showed you a graph of the declining fertility rate globally
and in the developed countries.
So in the world as a whole,
as you've been told,
the uh,
the fertility client has not been enough to keep population from still going up
very rapidly.
We discussed that.
But in Europe,
Japan,
the advanced countries,
the fertility client has,
uh,
caused population come down enough where these countries are now facing rather
serious problems of reduced of a,
of a decline,
possibly declined in their population.
Certainly a change in the age structure.
And this is what Michael is an expert on.
And so that is what he will discuss today as soon as I show.
Well,
thank you very much.
Uh,
Doctor Wyman and his pleasure to be here.
And I just want to say you're a very lucky bunch of undergraduates to have
Robert Wyman as your professor.
Uh,
he's,
uh,
I,
I've heard him lecture and I know him and he's a wonderful,
uh,
academic and scholar.
Um,
going through that list of,
um,
going through that list of publications,
uh,
makes me realize why my wife has been so annoyed with me for the 40 years nearly
that we'd been married because a lot of that work has had to be done when I
wasn't an academic.
And that means it comes out of your hide or out of your summer holidays or
weekends or evenings.
But it's,
uh,
interesting,
exciting and wonderful to do and,
and I've enjoyed doing it.
Uh,
I know that you've been discussing,
uh,
cause I've seen your prospectus for this,
excellent course.
Uh,
I know you've been discussing,
um,
high fertility rates and the demographic transition and you know,
therefore that high fertility has attracted a great deal of attention,
um,
for at least two centuries.
Um,
uh,
and has always been related to poverty issues,
concerns about poverty under development,
developing countries and so on or poverty back in the,
uh,
in the 18 hundreds when,
when Malthus was writing and also related to concerns about the environment and
so on.
What,
what is less known though is that for at least a hundred years of those two
centuries,
uh,
there has been discussion about low fertility as a problem as well.
And this has a long,
and,
uh,
I would say tumultuous history,
lots of proponents,
uh,
worrying about it,
often very prominent people in politics or science,
I would say the debates have been plagued by misunderstanding and confusion as
have the debates about high fertility.
So there's something about population that stimulates misunderstanding and
confusion.
Now,
in general,
low fertility has been linked to a decline in power.
You have to think about this,
and in political and economic terms,
national power empires,
the decline of empires and so on.
But the links have been made,
but it's often very fuzzy as to what the causal flow is.
Is,
is the low fertility a cause of the decline of empires or decline of national
power,
or is it a symptom?
And often the commentators don't make it very clear what they're talking about.
Those of you who know the French debates about these issues,
we'll know that it's a very prominent feature of French intellectual discourse
going back into the 1870s,
for example.
But the French are hardly alone in this.
Uh,
you will find many such anxieties expressed in Germany in the 30s in Great
Britain,
Sweden,
you asked Russia,
et cetera.
And,
um,
more recently,
let's say over the past four decades or so,
in eastern Europe,
in Japan,
in the u s certainly and,
uh,
in,
in the Asian Tigers,
uh,
most recently,
Singapore,
Taiwan,
and Korea,
because it's about power,
national power or sub national power,
um,
low fertility has long been closely tied to a political ideology and to cultural
values.
And in some cases,
low fertility is even been used as a tool to achieve desired social policies.
Uh,
but I want to make one point that I hope you'll take away from this,
which is that the concern about low fertility has never ever been solely about
the number of warm bodies,
human being warm bodies.
That is,
but instead,
it's been visualized through the lens of the socio cultural values.
Um,
the reason I say it's never been about warm bodies can be illustrated there
because if what I said is not true,
there really could never have been any concern about fertility since at least
1950.
The world's population,
as you see,
has grown dramatically over that half century.
And,
uh,
neither could there be any concern about future,
population?
Uh,
demographic trends because the projections,
no matter which variant you take from the UN,
all shows substantial growth going forward.
So in,
in reality,
the fears about low fertility are always framed in terms of regional or national
or religious or ethnic or subnational populations defined culturally.
Um,
and I,
I would put it rather crudely if I may,
that,
um,
since the onset of mortality declined,
which you've heard about already,
at least two centuries go,
there have never been any shortages of humans.
There have only been perceived or relative shortages of particular kinds of
humans.
And the most critical category is national groups in these discussions.
And then you can get into language or religion or the other subgroups.
Uh,
to give you an example of this,
I just want to point out that,
um,
when he was mayor of Paris,
the later president of the Republic of France,
Jacques Chirac sheer rock,
uh,
he warned about the decline in the population of France.
This is consistent with French,
uh,
perspectives that right to left all French people think that there are too few
French people.
Uh,
and uh,
yet at the same time he urged the repatriation of Arab immigrants and the
restriction of future immigration.
So I mean not a classically shows you that it's not about the number of warm
bodies,
it's about the number of French or bodies in France.
There is no ideological uniformity in these things.
I've already said that in France,
the,
the range of concerns is right from the left to the right,
right across the political spectrum.
A democratic thinkers of um,
what you might call liberal in the US are left wing in,
in Europe say,
and of conservative orientations have all expressed about this in one form or
another.
Those are democratic thinkers,
non democratic thinkers,
so such as the nationalist,
right.
And in Interwar,
Germany and Italy and nationalist parties such as the Front Nazionale and uh,
in France and other European countries have expressed such concerns as has or
have the authoritarian lefts of Stalin and Nicolae Ceausescu in Romania.
There's a whole story about Romania,
which I written about.
If you want to see a bizarre situation read about what the Romanian government
did in 19 in the 1960s on the political right.
Low fertility has generally been seen as a threat to national power,
imperial power or from the point of view of some with a more economics
orientation,
uh,
to the capacity to restrain wages and the power of unions.
Many on the right have also expressed alarm about fertility differentials
between social classes and races,
ethnic groups and so forth.
But frankly,
such concerns are subliminal,
but they're in other political persuasions then than the right.
And meanwhile,
as I said,
the political left has often shared these nationalistic and strategic concerns
in the 1930s Hitler's Germany and adopted very aggressive pro natalist policies
to raise fertility in Germany.
But so did Stalin's USSR,
same time,
same place or different places,
same policies in many ways.
And there,
then there were the socialist states.
I mentioned John [inaudible] had a very strong pro natalist policy,
but in the meantime,
the People's Republic of China went from prenatal isn't too strong.
The antenatal is probably the most energetic fertility reduction policy in world
history,
same country,
same party in control,
very tick taking population very significantly now in the west,
the Democratic Left has concentrated generally on the threat posed by low
fertility to their desires to expand and strengthen the the welfare state.
And in fact,
if you look in the 30s,
you'll see a fascinating debate led by the mere dolls,
prominent economists,
Nobel laureates later,
uh,
of the left in Sweden who promoted what came to be called the welfare state to
the conservative parties in Sweden on the grounds that they needed to do
something to raise fertility.
And that was the way to do it.
If they didn't raise fertility,
there would be no Swedes left in 50 years or so.
And they actually co-opted the right successfully into supporting the welfare
state that they promoted.
What about demographers?
They've been involved in this stuff.
Yes,
they have,
including some very prominent ones.
One reason for this was the discovery.
The development in the 30s by demographers have some very powerful concepts and
techniques.
I don't know if you've actually studied yet.
The intrinsic rate of increase net reproduction rate,
total fertility rate and demographic projection models.
All of these being developed tech,
uh,
being technologies developed in the 30s.
Uh,
and these,
um,
lead to predictions from demographers that the population of the United Kingdom
for example,
from the 1930s to the 1960s would declined very sharply.
And there were some very pathetic novels and,
and uh,
and academic books written with titles like twilight of parenthood,
um,
race suicide and other such tomes that forecast using demographic projection
models that there would be too few whatevers.
What's the relevant group?
Now in some respects,
these,
these were flawed predictions.
Obviously it didn't happen and they arose from misunderstanding because these
were new technologies that had only recently been understood and developed and
there was a typical excess of enthusiasm,
academic enthusiasm.
They really thought they had developed a window into the distant future.
They could project the population using intrinsic rates of increase and
projection models and they could see 50 years into the future they thought they
were wrong.
All of those projections proved to be empirically wrong.
And we know better now because we've seen they were wrong.
It helps to actually see things go so badly wrong,
but the same errors of believing demographic projections to be forecasts of
future populations are being made right now as we speak mostly by non
demographers.
Demographers have all learned,
they can't believe projections as predictions.
Uh,
but non demographers haven't learned that lesson or don't want to learn that
lesson and they use these projections to forecast decline of the West decline of
the Soviet Union decline of Russia,
decline of Italy,
whatever category they want to talk about.
What about,
I said there were a few very distinguished demographers who also did this.
Yes.
Um,
the most prominent was the great French demographer outlay Sovi a very
distinguished man.
Indeed,
uh,
probably the dean of a French demographers,
he did this kind of relationship of low fertility equals decline for most of his
professional career for 40 years.
Basically.
And let me just list for you some of the events in history that he attributed to
fertility rates being too low.
He said the decadence of ancient Athens and then of Rome,
that's item one.
The failure of France to industrialize
the decline of the French navy in the 19th century.
The collapse of the French army before the Germans in 1940,
he used very evocative language.
Uh,
he said,
uh,
for example,
the terrible failure of 1940 more moral than material must be linked in part to
this dangerous sclerosis resulting from low birth rate.
We saw all too often during the occupation,
German occupation,
old men leaning weirdly towards the survival solution at the time that the
young,
that's the resistance we're taking part in the national impulse towards
independence and liberty.
This crucial effect of our senility is it not a grave warning
d population for friends carries with it fatally a general legacy of decadence.
So you see how powerful the rhetoric can be in this area.
I do want,
do not want you to get the impression that demographers shared.
So these lifelong concern about fertility being too low.
To the contrary,
they were not widely shared among demographers.
After all the PR,
the gloomy forecast of the 30s proved to be wrong.
So the past is one of confusion and anxiety.
What about the future?
I'd say it's likely to be a future of great unpredictability.
The truth is that currently we are in a period of low fertility rates that are
without precedent in there.
Lowness if you will,
their smallness and without precedent in how widespread they have become around
the world and having no precedent,
we actually lack any way of knowing if they will continue at the east very low
levels,
if they'll rise somewhat,
perhaps even above the magic 2.11 replacement level or could they decline
further two levels such as the league table leaders and low fertility,
which would be surprisingly enough,
Italy,
Spain,
Hong Kong,
we don't know anybody who tells you they know.
Um,
you should not believe.
They have no way of knowing.
We do know that the law,
very low fertility,
the 30s was short lived and but then it was followed by a substantial baby boom
in some countries that had low fertility in the 30s and not in others.
So all I can say to you is,
why don't you all come back for your 50th reunion at Yale in 50 years and we'll
have a talk about weather fertility rates stayed very low,
went lower or rows in these countries with very low.
That's the only way we're ever going to know
this graph will surely be wrong as a prediction.
I will predict that.
Uh,
and there's a,
there's an irony here.
Uh,
we,
uh,
we had moved from a society in which 90% of women had no effective control over
their fertility to the society in which 90% of women do have effective control
of their fertility,
rational control of their fertility.
The result is that analysts,
demographers,
and you,
um,
are less able to rationally anticipate what they will collectively do now that
they individually,
rationally have control over their fertility.
A very wide range of population projections as plausible.
That's just a narrow range compared to some you could do if you wanted to make.
These are quite conservative assumptions on the high side and the low side.
So under these kinds of conditions of really profound uncertainty,
can we offer any cautious interpretations of historical experience that might
provide us with some kind of insight into the future?
Well,
I'll offer a few and you can shoot me down if you would like to do so.
First.
I think it's nearly inevitable that we'll see populations with much older age
structures,
much older age compositions than those of the past.
That's the consequence of low fertility.
Of course if there's a nuclear catastrophe or some other catastrophe,
all bets are off.
None of none of these projections or future looks can assume catastrophe.
The only way to return to the youthful age structures of the past would be to
have very substantial fertility increases to those of the past and to sustain
those very high fertility rates.
This intern would apply,
would imply rapid population increase ad infinitum and I think most of you know
that that's not likely to happen.
Now,
my other point here is that societies that have very low fertility rates,
like 1.1 child per woman on average that you might find in Italy or Japan,
Japan's a little higher but 1.3 in Japan,
I think,
um,
it would be desirable.
This is a value judgment on my part.
It would be desirable for fertility rates to rise somewhat to more moderate
levels,
but I don't think they will ever rise in those countries to the levels,
uh,
pre transition.
So the challenge is going to be to find creative mechanisms to smooth the
transition from younger to older demographic age structures and to put in place
adaptive mechanisms that will allow such societies to prosper,
uh,
over the longer term under these new conditions.
The second point I'd like to make is that we are in danger collectively of
making two errors of demographic interpretation and these are both significant
errors.
First,
we are in danger of putting on do emphasis upon what are called period rates.
Have you discussed period rates?
Okay.
We are in danger of um,
focusing on period rates.
I've just done it myself at one point,
one child per woman for Italy,
even though we know they are distorted rates,
they're well below the underlying rates of how many children the average woman
will have when she finishes their child bearing.
That's a cohort,
right?
And second danger is,
and we're doing it every day,
miss specifying the category aged and thereby misconstruing what demographic
aging means.
Let me say a few words about both of those.
In Italy,
Spain,
Greece,
Portugal,
Ireland,
countries like that.
In Europe,
there have been significant increases in the mean age of marriage and hence the
mean age of first birth.
Typically these are large increases by demographic standards and they are large
enough to cause distortions in the period rates over the time period during
which the mean age of childbearing is rising.
This is a well known phenomenon to demographers.
It's not well understood among political leaderships.
When I was,
um,
on working on the hill running a congressional committee,
I learned not to use the term cohort because as soon as I said cohort,
the congressman would say,
you mean your friends,
your cohort?
And I said,
no,
it's uh,
you know,
it's a generation concept.
Oh,
I don't get it.
You know,
don't,
don't bother me with the facts,
but even the term,
uh,
is misunderstood.
Given that it's really easy to distort,
uh,
for that kind of audience.
If you want to make the case that,
uh,
we're all going to hell in a handbasket to distort these period rates and say
this is what's going to continue indefinitely into the future
varied rate.
Okay.
Period rate is,
um,
it is expressed.
Let's say,
let's take the total fertility rate,
which is a period rate.
It is synthetic in the sense that it is an attempt to summarize the fertility
behavior.
Let's say in 2009 of women,
demographers care only about women by the way,
of women of all ages.
So it's the fertility rates of women 15 to 1920 and 24.
These are different cohorts.
As you can see in 2009.
They're born in different years.
They each have a characteristic fertility rate by age.
If you sum up
the rate of all of those age groups in a given year,
you will get a period rate,
which is an attempt to summarize the overall fertility behavior of the entire
population of all ages.
And then we express it probably confusingly in terms such as 1.1 child per woman
or 2.1 child's children per
per woman.
It's not actually any real woman.
It's a synthetic woman,
a the best kind of women.
Yeah.
If you,
uh,
another way to imagine this,
imagine you had,
um,
a thousand female demographers that's a frightening prospect when you think
about it.
And uh,
they formed a pact,
they were all age 15.
So there are 15 year old,
uh,
demographers and they form a PAC that they will bear children collectively at
the rate of each age group in that year that they make the pact right through
their reproductive lifespan at the end of their reproductive life span,
40 say or 45,
they collectively would have an average children ever born equal to the total
fertility rate for that year.
But of course,
that would never happen.
I mean,
I'm just trying to give you an ask you to imagine what the rates mean.
The problem with the rate,
well,
let me say what's good about the period rates.
They give you a summary of what's going on in a year or in a five year period.
That's why it's called a period,
right?
It's a current kind of summary,
The cohort rates don't do that.
They tell you how many children,
women age 45 today had through their entire lifespan.
The problem with the period rates is that they can be distorted if women delay
or accelerate their child bearing each year.
If you,
if there's a delay,
they may end up with the same number of children when they finish their
childbearing,
but they're stretch it out over more years,
so the annual rates,
the period rates are depressed.
Therefore we know that's happening in southern Europe.
We know it's not happening in Europe,
so low rates and central Europe are not distorted in this way.
The low rates and southern Europe are distorted in this way and that's probably
enough about period rate.
Now.
I said the second possible error is the miss specification by demographers and
others of the boundaries of the age dependency category convention.
When do you get to be aged?
Dependent answer 65
where did that number come from?
Arbitrary.
Who came up with it?
The people who designed the Social Security Act of 1935 who had to decide at
what age did a person qualify for a social security pension?
Why did they say 65 well,
actually the,
initially they were going to say 70 because they were copying Bismark's social
insurance scheme from the 19th century and the Bismarck system,
you've got your state pension at age 70
but it was a time of mass unemployment and so there was a desire to encourage
older workers to leave the workforce,
to make room for unemployed younger workers,
so they moved it down by five years,
65 it's been that way in the statistics and the data ever since.
Demographers have not adjusted to the reality that the meaning of 65 in 1935 was
very different from the meeting of 65 and 2005 or 2009.
And uh,
that's a problem because we,
we will,
um,
spend a lot of time calculating to the third decimal place,
the age of dependency ratio.
Uh,
and,
and yet we know that the meaning of the boundary between a working age and age
and dependency,
uh,
is increasingly out of touch with reality.
Same is true by the way,
the young dependency ratio,
youthful dependency ratio,
which is usually set at age 15 or 19 on grounds,
that after that people become productive,
uh,
labor force people like you,
right?
So,
so that's all changed to a,
but we still stick to these boundaries and were misleading ourselves and
everyone else.
I'm afraid by doing that.
There are a lot of alternatives to this.
I won't go into them,
but one obvious possibility would be to shift the age boundaries upward for both
the youthful and the older boundaries,
safer to 20 years and 70 years rather than 15 and 65.
That would make sense.
You'd want to keep the old series as well because you'd,
uh,
you'd want to have some comparability over time,
but to have an alternative,
a ratio would be useful.
Another possibility would be to fix the number of years,
uh,
of remaining life expectancy rather than the age,
the absolute age as the boundary between age of dependency and working age.
Now let me talk a bit about policy responses to very low fertility.
There are basically two basic types of policy responses that have been strongly
urged,
first measures to increase fertility.
That's a pretty obvious and direct one and second measures to adapt to low
fertility over the longer term.
Uh,
I am not embracing any of these recommendations,
but I do want to,
um,
uh,
give you the analytic possibilities that might,
that have been put forward first.
And this will offend most of you.
Uh,
it has been urged and implemented in some countries to limit access to fertility
control.
If you banned contraception,
abortion,
et cetera,
sterilization fertility rates would go up.
That's basically what Cha Jessica in Romania did in 1966.
Uh,
this would be,
um,
probably,
uh,
unworkable in liberal democracy.
Romania is not a liberal democracy to say the least and it uh,
would be unacceptable in many other ways.
It would probably result in a revolution in the United States,
but that's analytically a possibility.
Second economic incentives to encourage higher fertility and these have come in
many forms in the past,
a cop out cash bonuses for bearing a child or allowances annual payments per
child you have in the family from the government or tax preferences to people
with children.
Those are part of us tax law.
Of course these can be flat meaning each child is treated the same in terms of
the amount of bonus or tax incentive or they can be progressive.
I guess you put that in quotes with increasing amounts per for later births.
So you might not get,
you might give no incentive for the first birth,
but a big incentive for the third birth for example.
Or you could give in kind benefits.
For example,
in much of eastern Europe,
families with more than a two children had access to larger and preferential
flats,
preferred flats,
government flats.
They got preference in that way or subsidized housing or you could give,
uh,
early retirement bonuses to people.
You could say,
well,
a woman who has three or more children can retire at age 55 instead of 65.
That would be an incentive,
uh,
in,
in both the Soviet Union in the 30s and in Nazi Germany and Thirties,
women got prizes,
gold metals,
mother heroin,
uh,
awards,
gold medals for eight or more children for example,
in the,
in the Soviet Union.
Or You could counter weight existing disincentives to large families,
for example,
by um,
facilitating female labor force participation for women who have children in
various ways.
The French crest system,
which is a government financed early childhood before the s the schools start
system of childcare is an example of doing that.
The Swedish government has lots of policies of this kind.
So those are benign examples where there's some harsh examples.
Um,
you could,
uh,
take measures to deter female labor force participation on grounds that you
think it conflicts with a maternal behavior.
Now among Western countries,
they've really been only a few that have adopted explicitly pro natalist
policies of these kinds.
Um,
France,
Luxembourg,
Greece,
Quebec come to mind.
Although other countries have policies they do not describe as pro natalist
policies.
They say their social policies,
but they have the implicit effect of being pro natalist and they don't
acknowledge that typically,
uh,
in France there have been proposals never adopted for an official maternal wage
that's called that in which mothers who stay at home with young children would
get monthly payments from the government.
They get paid to be mothers that would be calculated in those proposals at about
25% of the prevailing wage for employed women in uh,
the socialist countries,
former socialist countries of eastern Europe.
There were lots of these policies.
They've all disappeared or almost all of just feared since the fall of the
communist system.
But those countries had child allowances,
birth bonuses,
maternity leave at full pay for five months paid leave until the child is three
years of age and substantial subsidies and grants and kind the only non western
low fertility country that's pursued this kind of policy that I'm familiar with
that so far at least.
But there will be others on what surely,
uh,
is Singapore.
Singapore has embraced strong pro natalist policies and there've been some
modest ones in Korea,
Thailand and Malaysia in Singapore too.
They have policies about encouraging highly educated young men and women to meet
each other.
They have dating services.
They want them to meet each other and,
and,
and marry and have children,
which always causes amusement outside of Singapore.
They don't think it's funny.
They think it's perfectly sensible,
if it's fair to say that the impacts of these policies on are probably there,
but they're small impacts.
And in some countries they were very expensive policies as well,
but they didn't have much impact.
If you tried to do the kinds of things that eastern European socialist countries
did in the 80s,
proportionately in western countries,
the costs would be enormous.
Uh,
a third to a half of average wages.
for a family with two or three children for example,
the cost would be very large.
Now what about measures to adapt to low fertility over the long term?
Well,
first it's easier to adapt if the shifts are gradual.
So very low fertility countries having dramatic shifts in the age structure,
it makes it much harder for them.
And then I've already mentioned the question of the boundaries between
dependency and so,
and I won't repeat that,
um,
but it's fair to say that the elderly dependent population,
however defined is going to cost more than the youthful a dependent population,
mainly because of healthcare education is the main public investment in youthful
dependent population.
The rest of the costs of those children are borne by families.
But when it comes to the age of dependent population,
the families are no longer paying the costs and the healthcare costs are very
high and,
and rising.
And here,
I would have to say that of the fruit of the industrialized countries of the
West,
the u s has the largest problem in this regard,
not because it has the oldest age structure or the most rapidly growing elderly
population,
but because it is politically and capable of controlling its expenditure on
health care and that's a generic problem in the society,
but it has special importance for the elderly aid structure.
What could governments do where they could modify the terms of the social
pension provisions?
They could shift the effective age of retirement,
they could prioritize part of the pension system.
Uh,
they could,
um,
subject pension benefits of well off retirees to a substantial income taxation.
Um,
but in fact the politics of pension policy and most of these countries have
operated in the other direction in the opposite direction.
Most countries,
if anything,
you've taken measures to lower the pension age until recently when they started
gradually now to reverse the lowering of pension ages that they engage in in the
sixties and seventies as far as the youthful population is concerned,
it's going to be smaller with these low fertility populations.
Well,
one could certainly convert age related facilities such as schools for other
purposes.
And going forward it would make a lot of sense to design new schools in a
flexible way so they're easier to convert for other purposes,
which leads me finally to immigration.
Immigration
is often put forward as a way to deal with an aging population.
And the truth is that the potential pool of immigrants to low fertility
countries,
the potential pool is very large and it could easily be tapped.
So,
um,
in fact,
many of these countries are having problems restraining the flow,
which is exceeding what they would like it to be.
So it would be quite simple for a low fertility country,
any of the ones I've mentioned to simply augment their populations by allowing
additional immigration,
that's,
it sounds a lot easier than changing the pension system and then all the other
systems.
But now let me take you back to my point about concerns about low fertility not
being about the number of warm bodies,
but about the numbers defined as part of the nation or other ethnic or cultural
group.
So that's the paradox.
Under conditions of very low fertility,
substantial immigration would produce very rapid transformation of the
composition of a population socio culturally defined.
And historically such rapid changes have led to passionate public opposition.
So the irony here is that while you might think as an analyst sitting here and
lecture room at Yale,
that uh,
uh,
why not just have more warm bodies immigrate and that'll take care of the issue.
It's exactly in a low fertility setting that the public opposition is strongest
to increased or substantial immigration.
There are some examples in which,
um,
immigration can be of a Pete by people who are defined as part of,
or similar to the indigenous population.
And in those cases,
there's less,
typically less opposition.
And I can give you a few examples like the postwar migration of,
um,
uh,
east Germans to West Germany for example,
or the German so-called Germans from the Volga Germans from Russia to Germany,
which turned out to be quite controversial,
but they were defined as Germans returning home even though their ancestors had
left 300 years earlier.
The Pew hadn't wire to France,
uh,
after the collapse of the,
the French empire in Africa,
mostly the re the return.
Think about that.
The return of Jews from North Africa to the new state of Israel,
of Italians,
uh,
or Italian Argentinians rather to Arjun to Italy,
um,
of a Japanese origin,
people,
the Nisai,
uh,
from Brazil and Peru to Japan,
of Angolan colonial settlers to Portugal.
So there are examples of this kind of migration being less controversial.
And I think one should also say that moderate levels of immigration do not
appear to be all that controversial.
This is not a question of people being passionately against immigration,
but it's a question of quantity.
And this will lead me if I can get this to move forward.
Oh,
here's,
here's the Jacques rock quote,
which I'm,
I meant to show you.
I'll let you read it.
So you see,
she rock was saying
that in 2004,
we already know what the population was in 2004,
but that
Europe would be empty in 2004.
He said that in 1984 and a one thing that demographers have learned is never
make a prediction over a time span in which you might still be alive because you
will probably always be wrong.
A sheer rock was clearly wrong.
What I want to talk about is a study,
and this will be my last section here.
I study,
uh,
of,
the question of substituting,
um,
immigration for missed fertility in low fertility societies.
It was a study done by the United Nations population division in 2000.
It asks the question how many immigrants would be needed to compensate for low
fertility in Europe?
And the answer was a lot.
This was no surprise to the UN population division or two demographers.
Uh,
but it was a surprise to the New York Times,
which in 2001,
um,
ran this a story or 2000,
I guess it is second January,
2000,
uh,
ran this story,
picked up by the Herald Tribune in Paris and so on,
um,
about this study.
Uh,
I know a little bit about the history of why it was published on the 2nd of
January,
2000,
which I can tell you because it's a story about how the press works.
The study had been filed months before by the journalist Barbara Crossette and
was literally filed in a file cabinet,
had not been published.
And then on the 2nd of January day after New Year's slow news day,
nothing was happening.
The editor on duty,
he said,
oh,
we had that story,
you know,
from six months ago.
Let's just throw that in the paper.
They put it in.
The paper had already been written and edited.
And notice the headline here,
um,
the subhead,
it's the American way.
You can imagine how this appealed to the nationalists in various European
countries.
Europe stares at a future built by immigrants.
It's the American way.
The reaction,
uh,
was,
um,
describe to me by the head of the UN population division.
Uh,
in one word he said it was mayhem.
They started to get calls almost immediately from almost every newspaper in
Europe.
The secretary general of the United Nations got calls from most European
countries,
from the governments,
and not surprisingly,
the secretary general,
it's office called over to the population division and said,
could you please send us the study?
The truth is there was no study.
They had done some back of the envelope calculations and had done a one page
talking points thing for a general assembly meeting that they thought it might
come at a up at.
Um,
so what they did was the press release,
that was I think,
two pages summarizing the back of the envelope calculations and within a few
days,
uh,
Lamond let's see if I have the Lamond story here.
Here's the press release.
Here's the Lamond I think.
MMM.
And uh,
Lamanda actually dropped the question mark at the end of the title of the,
of the press release.
You see that the press release says replacement migration.
Is it a solution to declining and aging populations and Lamond translated it as
a solution to declining and et cetera populations.
MMM.
There was suddenly a big story in Europe.
Here we have Le Figaro,
the report that alarmed Europe or alarms Europe.
It was translated,
I think there's an economist article here.
Here's a cartoon from Figaro saying,
uh,
what's the distance to Europe,
to the United Nations,
uh,
et Cetera,
man.
And a woman talking over the about that.
Here's The economist.
Fewer and wrinklier Europeans,
um,
all the major German newspapers had articles,
uh,
Belgium,
Spanish,
Italian,
the French TV,
uh,
main channel sent crews to the UN to interview the authors of the study.
There was still no study.
All there was with that press release that you saw before.
Well,
for some reason the secretary general took the view that they should now do the
study.
And they did this study.
And unfortunately what happened was that the press in Europe interpreted the UN
study or the press release as UN recommendation to European countries to admit
more immigrants.
So,
um,
the United Nations is preparing a new report,
which will argue that Europe may need to accept many more migrants over the next
50 years to maintain population levels and the size of its workforce.
That's not,
they did do the study very quickly.
It's not what the study did.
This is a,
this is an inventory of all the articles that were published after the press
release.
What are they actually find?
Well,
what they did were hypothetical scenarios to 2050,
and they asked the following questions among others,
how many immigrants would key countries need to prevent decline in the total
population,
assuming that their projections on fertility were accurate to hold constant the
population 1565 to 65.
There we are again with those 15 and 65 age boundaries and to hold constant what
they call the potential support ratio,
which they defined as the ratio of people of working age,
meaning 15 to 64,
uh,
to those who are aged dependent meaning 65 and over
and for the last,
uh,
which was in a way the most important one here with the numbers they came up
with,
that Germany would need 188 million immigrants by 2050.
At which point 80% of the population within the boundaries of Germany would be
represented by those immigrants and their offspring.
Italy would need 120 million.
And you see the percentages here,
always four fifths of the population would be accounted for by immigrants and
their offspring,
the u s even the u s which would need 593 million immigrants who would be at 73%
even with its higher fertility rates.
So the,
the paradox here is that if you combine low fertility with high immigration from
an economic view or let's say our Yale undergraduate perspective,
uh,
immigrants or substitutes or compliments their workers there,
they have skills,
they bring skills,
they pay taxes,
they subsidize retirement for older residents.
Um,
but the public view is that immigrants are human beings,
that they have cultures,
religions,
politics,
languages.
So if fertility is low,
immigration is less acceptable to Publix.
Then if fertility is high or higher,
meanwhile elite like us take that more economic perspective.
I think probably if we did a survey of this group,
we would be much more positive about increasing immigration.
Then with the public at large and the outcomes of this are really unknowable.
There's been a lot of heat.
There hasn't been a lot of light about international migration.
Um,
the data are week.
Is it a fertility data are a much better mortality data or the best demographic
data for utility Beta with data are the second best migration data are by far
the worst.
They are very weak,
but we think they were about 200 million international migrants around now and
then it's gone up about two thirds,
uh,
in 15 years increasing at about 2.3 million per year.
If you put them all together,
where does the,
where do they fit?
200 million would be the fifth largest population in the world.
So it's a nontrivial number,
but it's a very small fraction of the world's population.
Like 3% or less.
We have tens of millions of people migrating,
but overwhelmingly the majority of people do not migrate.
So just keep all of those paradoxes in your head about international migration
in absolute terms.
The U s has the largest number of foreign born people at 35 million in 2000 and
the Russian Federation is next.
And here if you can read that.
Yeah,
I guess you can,
you see the u s at the top there,
the Russian Federation,
and then the other countries are a lot smaller in terms of foreign born
residents.
If you look though at the percent of the population,
you got a different list than the one I just showed you of the different league
table.
The Persian Gulf states have the highest percentage of their population who are
immigrants or,
or um,
international migrants largely because they have substantial numbers,
small compared to the u s but substantial numbers of international migrants on
the base of a very small indigenous population.
Most of their migrants are temporary workers.
They're not immigrants in the sense that they're allowed to stay permanently.
So you have three quarters of the populations of the United Arab Emirates and
the Kattar who are foreign born.
Um,
and more than half in Kuwait.
I say here that Israel and Jordan are about 40%.
It depends on how you define the Palestinians and Jordan.
Uh,
but that if you call them international migrants,
then it's 40% or so in Jordan and then you can find a few European countries.
But they're tiny like Lichtenstein that have high percentages of foreign born
people,
but generally speaking,
the highest percentages are in small countries.
And here's the league table there.
I don't know if you can read it.
United Arab Emirates,
Kuwait,
Jordan,
Israel,
Singapore,
Oman,
Estonia,
Saudi Arabia,
Latvia,
Switzerland,
Australia,
New Zealand got ball Canada.
You see the big countries don't by and large peer in that league table.
Uh,
if you look at countries that have 50 million or more,
sorry,
we're starting about,
or we're starting to talk about significant population countries.
Um,
the percent of foreign born exceeds 10% in only three such countries in the
Ukraine,
in the u s and in France.
The Russian Federation and Germany are getting pretty close,
so we should include them probably,
but there aren't many others that are above 5%.
So I've already said that low fertility might imply increasing immigration and
there are plausible arguments about,
uh,
in favor of that to meet the labor force needs that employers say they have.
Um,
as there's more economic integration,
a more international migration is inevitable.
Uh,
and immigrants can arguably finance unsustainable pension systems pay as you are
in the pension systems,
but they're equally plausible counter arguments.
Uh,
and you're just going to have to decide for yourself.
I don't think anyone can convince you one way or another,
um,
of what's right here,
what's the proper mindset.
But one argument here would be that low fertility rates are likely going to be
temporary,
that that public opposition will prevent an increase of international migration
to very high levels.
And that these pay as you are in pension systems are going to be restructured.
And I am firmly on the fence on this.
I will sit uncomfortably on the fence as long as I can stand it.
It's painful to sit on the fence.
But,
uh,
in this case,
I don't think there's a clear,
uh,
correct position on these things.
So here,
summary and conclusions,
very low fertility now is widespread and it's continuing to spread.
I think the last I looked,
and don't quote me on this,
but last I looked,
um,
if you don't include China,
because China tilts everything,
it's 20% of the world's population.
So let's be conservative and not include China,
which does have below replacement fertility.
Without China,
40% of the world's population now lives in countries with below replacement
fertility and rising
with China.
60% of the world's population lives in such countries.
Uh,
in the past.
We know that these low fertility rates,
in fact,
not as low as some of the rates we see today have led to exaggerated a alarm and
to nationalist responses.
Fertility rates could rise in the future.
There's nothing to stop them.
Most sociologists,
anthropologists,
and demographies don't think they will,
but they have no way of knowing.
I don't think they will,
but I could easily be wrong.
But it's hard to increase fertility rates.
The policy in liberal democracies,
increased immigration is often invoked as a solution to the problems resulting
from very low fertility,
but it's not very effective and it's likely to stimulate its own passionate
opposition.
So my bottom line is,
and I'll stop with this,
that adaptive societies,
societies that are capable,
flexible enough to adapt to changing aid structures up and down and sideways are
likely to fare the best in the future.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
they've got to be some questions because I didn't explain some things that I
just asserted.
Okay.
So
when you think is causing this,
uh,
how long?
Yeah.
How long do we have?
Uh,
there,
uh,
there are a whole range of theories about this.
Uh,
there's a whole theoretical structure called the second demographic transition
theory,
which explains low fertility on grounds of secularization of societies,
the,
the collapse of a religious social control over behavior,
which relates heavily to marriage and child bearing of the,
uh,
rising labor force participation of women and women's labor force participation
being in conflict with um,
um,
fertility and child bearing and child rearing and a whole range of other things
that you might just characterize it.
Modernization.
And from this point of view,
theoretically low fertility is permanent and inevitable in,
um,
advanced societies that no society of that kind is going to ever again approach.
While they would,
I don't know if they would say this,
but they might,
wouldn't,
would not ever exceed replacement level.
And you'll have high percentages of women who will be a childless throughout
their lives.
Uh,
low marriage rates.
Why should anybody bother getting married when there's no problem and cohabiting
without being married socially,
culturally and legally?
If all the benefits of marriage can be accrued without needing to get married,
why bother?
And you actually see that,
especially in the Nordic countries where,
um,
very high percentages of the population,
again,
of women,
we can look at men too,
but women are the important fertility,
uh,
carriers if you will,
very high percentages of women age 30 are never married and don't look like they
ever will get married.
Very high rates of cohabitation.
And in the case of Sweden,
fertility has been rising from low levels under those circumstances,
which is posing some theoretical problems for the proponents of the second
demographic transition.
But we can't explain things like this.
Uh,
life is too complicated and,
and collective fertility behavior is too complicated to explain things like
this.
If you look at Japan,
for example,
in Japan,
you have very low
rates of marriage among women in their twenties.
It looks like Sweden,
uh,
in terms of marriage behavior,
but there's a huge difference in the percentage of births in Japan versus Sweden
that are outside of marriage.
If I remember correctly,
it's like 2% of births in Japan or outside of marriage.
And in Sweden it's almost 50% of births are outside marriage.
So you have the same marriage behavior roughly,
but higher fertility collectively in Sweden than you do in Japan.
Italy,
European country looks more like Japan in this respect that it looks like Sweden
or Germany.
I see.
Okay.
Or at least in America,
terrorism or war
within the government.
How much of a big issue with this and like at what time?
Well,
the US has high fertility by the standards of its peer countries.
It's very close to replacement level two.
Last time I looked at this 2.0 versus 2.1,
it was 1.1 or so in,
in uh,
Italy,
1.3 in Japan.
So there's less concern here.
Um,
then there is in among political elites in other countries,
what the US does have that most of them don't have,
however,
is a very large baby boom generation.
US had a big baby boom.
You've probably discussed this in previous lectures or you will be the u s
Canada,
uh,
Australia and New Zealand really where the four baby boom countries post World
War II and in the case of the u s fertility went from below replacement level
two,
3.7,
uh,
doubled.
Essentially it peaked in 1957 and started declining sharply in 1965 but there
was a period,
um,
uh,
the bit so called baby boom generation if you will in 1947 birth to 19,
65 who are now reaching the statutory retirement age and that bulge is going to
rapidly increase the proportion of the population in that post 65 age group for
about 20 years.
Because it's just,
you know,
it's just aging.
It's way through the age structure given that the u s government has proven
itself incapable of getting control over healthcare expenditures.
That will be a major crisis for the Medicare system.
I can predict that without any doubt,
whatever.
I don't know what's going to happen,
how it will be handled.
I just know it's going to be a major crisis.
Yes ma'am.
Yup.
Could you speak briefly,
my response to theorists are why it's moderate,
moderate to severe decline in populations is actually addressing social and
environmental concerns and that,
yes,
yes.
Uh,
I,
um,
I have a,
a firmly on the fence moderate position on these things.
I think both rapid population growth and rapid population decline are
problematic for societies.
There are too many things tied to age in the societies,
like public provision of schools versus healthcare and other things that rapid
shifts will cause problems.
So I think I alluded to this,
it's easier for societies to adjust to change if it's slower in general,
whether it would be desirable as some environmentalist.
Think for the population of the world to decline sharply from where it is,
six point some billion to whatever they think the carrying capacity of the earth
is.
And that's a highly speculative calculation of course is another matter.
And I don't think anybody can really resolve those debates.
People feel very strongly in both directions about those sorts of arguments.
But I would say myself that the optimal trajectory would be fertility rates plus
or minus 10 15% of replacement level,
not 50% above,
not 50% below not fluctuating a lot because if they fluctuate a lot,
it causes all kinds of oscillations in the age structure over 75 or 100 years.
And those are problematic for societies.
But uh,
you know,
moderation in all things is probably a good maxim for these kinds of long lived
slow changing but powerful there.
Their demography is like,
I think of demography as being like the tectonic plates of the earth.
You know,
it's moving very slowly by the standards of elections or economic collapses or
economic booms very slowly but huge force behind it and huge momentum behind it
too.
So you don't want to get in the way of tectonic plates if you can,
if you can avoid it.
I saw another hand.
Yes sir.
Hold on.
Policy perspective,
I guess specifically us are all warm American politics.
People who take taking consideration economic circumstances
from whose perspective
it governments or world?
Well,
the government doesn't have a brain.
I mean in the government is,
I would say it depends on the economy.
Um,
so if you had to choose,
this is a personal interpretation.
Uh,
it's not a fact.
If you had to choose,
let's say between a group of very highly skilled immigrants or a group of very
low skilled,
let's say illiterate immigrants and they were moving into society where the
mode,
most of the population was illiterate,
then it,
it wouldn't,
the,
the illiterate immigrant population would not be a serious issue really.
But if they're moving a society in which you have to be literate in order to
have any chance of economic sustainability and,
and advancement,
it would not be a good idea to import large numbers of people who are not going
to make it in that society.
So it's it,
it's a question of both the nature and characteristics of the immigrants and the
nature and characteristics of the economy and society,
and to which they're moving.
But governments,
you know,
if you're asking me what is the position of the U S or British government on
this,
they don't really have one.
You know,
they,
it's just the pushing and shoving of different interest groups and wherever the
vectors of pushing and shoving and up is what the government policy is,
but it's not necessarily thought through in a kind of logical way.
I think I saw one other hand,
we were running out of time.
Good.
[inaudible].